on aborde le deuxième sujet c'est celui
de ce rapport sénatorial et une
proposition à ces chocs en dix ans le
seul à ficeler bien il faut qu'il soit
inscrit au nombre des dérives sectaires
c'est donc une proposition d'un rapport
piloté par deux sénateurs l'un la
république en marche l'autre union
centriste
on s'en souvient emmanuel manuel valls
parle l'ex premier ministre avait voulu
aussi interdire le salafisme
alors est-ce une proposition efficaces
réalistes
en attendant l'acta est accusée de ne
rien faire par une partie de
l'opposition pour endiguer cette menace
terroriste c'est l'avis de guillaume
larrivé secrétaire général délégué des
républicains et député de l'yonne il
était ce matin sur la chaîne
parlementaire
je constate que sur cette question
majeure de la lutte contre l'islamisme
qui est un projet politique de
subversion de notre pays
je constate pardon que depuis 13 mois
maintenant la majorité se tourner les
pouces si vous permettez cette
expression familière donc il est
vraiment grand temps d'agir ce qu'on
peut pas accepter qu'ils aient une
partie du territoire national une partie
de la communauté nationale qui en
réalité fasse sécession et qu'ils soient
aujourd'hui soumise à la charia d'accord
à tous la majorité se tourner les pouces
sur la question du terrorisme et la
menace c'est pas le sujet préféré de la
majorité actuelle faut bien dire c'est
un sujet où on voit se recomposer les
clivages que macro on nous avait promis
disparaître sur des sujets comme ça y
compris au sein du groupe la république
en marche et du parti on voit bien la
gauche renette la droite renaître et
derrière des problématiques et aussi
beaucoup de d'ambiguïté
c'est un vrai sujet et le sujet est
compliqué à régler le rapport sénatorial
il a il al'avantage d'explorer une piste
qui effectivement la dérive sectaire
après on sait qu'il ya plusieurs types
de salafisme salafisme s'est pas
uniquement un salafisme jihadiste qui
tend à des opérations terroristes c'est
d'abord majoritairement dans ce pays je
dirais une une bataille idéologique pour
reprendre en main une communauté
musulmane que les salafis juge perverti
par l'occident et par la modernité et la
ramener dans une approche beaucoup plus
littéral beaucoup plus traditionalistes
de la pratique de l'islam donc les
salafistes pour la majorité en france
n'ont aucun intérêt à voir se multiplier
les opérations terroristes
ils sont très contents de pouvoir
continuer à travailler dans les écoles
dans les domaines associatif dans le
domaine humanitaire
sans faire de bruit en progressant par
rapport leur bataille idéologique
donc effectivement comment les
appréhender sans remettre en cause des
valeurs importantes dans notre société
que sont la liberté d'association la
liberté d'expression la liberté
d'opinion
cette idée d'inscrire moi je trouve que
c'est malin de prendre ça sous l'aspect
c'est clair avec une vraie difficulté
juridique c'est que dès que vous
commencez à appliquer le mot secte un
fait religieux
ben vous ouvrez effectivement la boîte
de pandore et et vous créer des
réactions très épidermique dans les
milieux religieux je dirais
institutionnels traditionnels
que ce soit les catholiques les
protestants ou la communauté juive et
donc on voit bien qu'il ya un défi à
relever qui est un défi juridique en
france c'est-à-dire à où est ce qu'on
met le curseur
comment est-ce qu'on peut interdire par
exemple un des parents de faire porter
des vêtements religieux à leurs enfants
au plus bas âge des vêtements religieux
qui les discriminent socialement joie on
voit bien que c'est le cas d'un certain
nombre de jeunes femmes et de très
jeunes filles de plus en plus dans
certains dans certains quartiers en
france mais la réponse qui doit être
juridique parce qu'on est dans un état
de droit elle est difficile à trouver
et moi je pense que c'est intéressant
qu'on ici une proposition qui viennent à
la fois
enfin qui viennent de deux familles
politiques différentes aux seynois du
moulin sur cette question précise de
possibilité d'inscrire son nom
oui mais c'est bien mais ça n'ira pas
sûrement pas assez loin pourquoi parce
que le qualificatif de secte on sait
très bien que la jurisprudence le
l'évaluent de manière très très très
méticuleuse et il faut tout à l'ensemble
des critères et donc on est parti pour
des batailles juridiques pour dire oui
c'était l'association est une secte
et puis qu'est ce qu'ils ont qualifié
l'emprise aussi bien sûr mais qu'est ce
qui empêche toute façon une association
salafistes 10 août dont la mosquée a été
fermée de se reconstituer sous un autre
nom du droit non nous on est passé à
l'effacement gert l école on gère une
salle de sport dont on se rend compte
finalement que c'est une salle de prière
ça arrive très fréquemment
en fait on passe vraiment entre les
mailles du filet faut dire on n'est pas
forcément aidés par des par une
tradition très libéral de la justice qui
pouvait avoir cessé sa cohérence l'ours
qui avant la menace salafiste mais là on
parle de la menace salafiste mais il ya
aussi
et alors les chiffres c'est exactement
il ya 120 mosquées salafistes et
quelques-unes 11 h trois ont été fermés
mais elles ont réouvert parce que
notamment ils ont gagné ce regorgent
hills mais il ya aussi 147 mosquée
tabligh et 200 masques et de l'udf donc
vous mettez ça bout à bout les sources
que je donne ces services centrale du
renseignement intérieur hier on se rend
compte que oui moi je suis d'accord avec
ce rapport sénatorial ou sssa
sénatoriales le gouvernement n'est pas
la hauteur il ya tout ce qu'il faut en
matière de renseignement et après les
décisions elles elles arrivent au compte
gouttes
samcon et puis on les découvre qu'au
bout d'un attentat bas que en fait 1,2
le terroriste était fichiers c'est qu'on
n'a rien fait parce qu'on peut pas
suivre tout le monde alors gouvernement
pas à la hauteur où finalement absence
de nécessité de faire un plan un énième
plan et applications de ce qui existe et
de la législation
ils sont pas à la hauteur depuis
longtemps le premier rapport alarmiste
et daté de 2004 il a été enterré et on a
continué à enterrer et c'est vrai que si
des jeunes avaient pas fait des pas
survenu on aurait continué à laisser
s'enkyster s'enraciner toute une série
de pratiques et dérives que moi je crois
qu'ils sont intolérables
au regard de nos valeurs et de nos
standards et puis en plus qui sont pas
dans une voie d'extinction sont plutôt
en voie de prosélytisme développement
donc ça ça ça a des racines qui sont
très profondes parce qu'on aurait dû dès
le départ appartement mon a commencé à
accepter une immigration nouvelle avec
une religion nouvelle il fallait poser
le problème dès les années 60 se peut
dire qu'est ce qu'on va faire ensemble
et comment est-ce qu'on va gérer cette
question là on a fait du ruisseau le
voilà tout va bien veut régler en
marchant et personne n'a à gérer la
question maintenant le mal il est
extrêmement profond dire que vous avez
vraiment effectivement dans des
quartiers dans des zones et dans une
partie de la population alors elle est
peut-être marginal mais il n'empêche
qu'elle pose un véritable problème il
suffit de voir sur internet
comment dès qu'on s'exprime sur ces
questions là quelle violence ça peut en
effet l'expérience la semaine dernière
quelle violence ça génère quand on dit
quelque chose
quand on monte prononce le mot charia en
disant qu'effectivement il ya des
pratiques à des dérives
il ya des comportements inacceptables ça
réagit extrêmement violemment alors ils
sont peut-être pas très nombreux mais en
ans il n'empêche que c'est c'est un vrai
symptômes alors l'idée de deux qualifiés
du point de vue juridique nation on est
dans un état de droit donc la seule
réponse et juridique ne peut pas être
policier au sens unique ministre hâtives
en disant on tape dedans joueurs état de
droit il faut effectivement un cadre
sauf que là ça va être effective en
prison mais ça suffira pas évidemment
derrière vous avez l'école évidemment
que vous avez une lutte internationale
sur les partis dits 51% dans ce rapport
un chiffre parmi d'autres
41 % d'augmentation de la
déscolarisation c'est-à-dire d'enfants
qui sont retirés de l'école avec leurs
camarades pourraient être scolarisés à
la maison
+41 % en deux ans je crois ne mettez pas
forcément que pour des questions
religieuses ou pour des questions liées
au salafisme
le problème c'est de la population qui
étudiait la tu dis oui
le problème c'est que
autant l'inscription comme groupements
sectaires c'est peut-être utile c'est
effectivement que vous disiez ça
n'empêchera pas forcément les gens de
dean salafistes ou les associations ne
sont montés à côté ce rapport qui pointe
pour moi il a deux avantages
1 il pointe les grosses carences et
insuffisances du dispositif actuel en
montrant que l'êta est complètement
dépassé par la situation n'est pas
capable de la prévenir il est
complètement dépassé et de il fait des
propositions qui sont très pratico
pratique autre que d'inscrire
juridiquement dans laquelle il revient
d'ailleurs sur ce qu'elle ait fait quand
même jusqu'à perdu françois hollande en
2016 c'est à dire est-ce qu'il faut
inscrire ou pas dans la constitution la
déchéance de nationalité pour les
binationaux
ce rapport trans partisan dit oui ce qu
avait quand même conduit la gauche à sa
perte en 2016 et surtout il dit qu'il
faut mieux gérer les sorties de prison
des gens qui ont été radicalisé parce
que là on est l'agent la nature on ne
sait pas comment faire ils ont beau être
fichier est ce même après leur sortie
toute façon le droit à jodie ne parlait
pas d'hier était mieux informer les
maires des fichiers est ce qu'ils sont
alors comme on parle des carences de
l'état effectivement il n'y a pas qu'une
carence juridique à une carence
administrative on parlera la des
vermines fonctionnaires qu'on veut mais
la déscolarisation ça se contrôle
l'état doit contrôler et contrôler y
compris jusque dans les familles comment
sont scolarisés par leurs parents enfin
compte éduqué par leurs parents les
enfants est ce que l'état les moyens de
le faire aujourd'hui y compris pour
cette population on parle des
fonctionnaires de bercy mais le problème
est un des uns des axes l'un des leviers
pour agir contre ces associations c'est
le contrôle des finances le contrôle de
l'origine des fonds le contrôle de il
vous mettriez des inspecteurs des impôts
plutôt que des policiers pour aller
contrôler ces associations cultuelles
culturel ou je ne sais quoi on
trouverait des moyens d'agir qu'on a
déjà utilisé par le passé dans d'autres
sujets et sur d'autres sur d'autres
schémas
donc il ya effectivement des leviers qui
sont dans le dans ce rapport mais qui
sont non seulement ce truc mais sous
dotées en moyens c'est d'être à avoir de
problème à gré cité le pouvoir politique
notamment certaines mairies 9e
neuf pas avoir les banlieues qui
s'enflamme donc on achète la paix
sociale et ont dit aux policiers
maintenant vous contrôlez juste l'entrée
et la sortie mais vous n'allez pas à
l'intérieur raison d'une certaine parce
que finalement l'état c'est nous l'état
c'est de la représentation elle est
fabriquée par la représentation
politique qui effectivement derrière va
fabriquer un état donc on est le reflet
de ça on a voulu ça il faut avoir
conscience que qu'est ce qu'on est prêt
aujourd'hui à accepter pour rétablir
l'état de droit
est ce qu'on est prêt à accepter qu'il
faut trois mois à notre dame des landes
pour arriver avec 2000 crs gendarmes et
policiers est ce qu'on est prêt à
accepter qu'on casse pendant cinq jours
un quartier entier à nantes parce qu'il
ya eu peut-être une bavure on verra la
suite de l'histoire et on laisse faire
pendant cinq nuits et ainsi de suite et
ça fait 30 ans que ça dure à chaque fois
qu'il ya un problème tout le monde
qu'elle soit si moi je suis de demain
victimes de n'importe quoi je vais pas
les casser tout autour de moi on tolère
ça donc on a on accepter cette espèce de
l'établissement d'un état parce que
l'acceptabilité général de la population
si demain on utilise vraiment les moyens
des moyens sérieux pour établir l'état
droit là où c'est nécessaire
est ce qu'on est prêt à accepter voilà
moi je pose la question vous avez
peut-être suivi cette affaire de l'imam
de toulouse qui a selon certains dans un
prêche fait un appel au meurtre des
juifs
céline pina qui est une ancienne élue
locale qui fait une tribune aujourd'hui
dans le figaro vox pour dire que tout ça
est assez scandaleux à ses yeux
cet imam ça fait une vingtaine d'années
je crois qu'il qu'il officie le fait des
prêches uniquement en arabe selon les
renseignements qu'on a
certains disent que régulièrement il ya
des dérives dans ses prêches
ça fait partie de ces illustrations on a
du mal finalement à trouver le
la bonne mesure on peut se demander si
effectivement le il vaudrait pas mieux
avoir des tout de suite une réponse
assez ferme
c'est indispensable enfin j'ai re est ce
qu'on peut accepter que dans un état
comme la france on ne puisse pas rentrer
dans un aussi un lieu de religion parce
qu'on n'est pas la même religion enfin
faire n'importe qui peut rendre dans une
église aujourd'hui
allez un vendredi dans une somme de
mosquée en tant que non non fidèles vous
rentrez pas donc j'ai rien que ce type
de pratique la tolérance de ce type
d'opposition de territoire et
complètement contraire aux principes
effectivement de valeur que nous devons
partager un moment donné ça doit être
des lieux ouverts et quand on pratique
se fait-il alors si celle ci s'est
qualifié derrière évidemment si c'est
vrai rien il faut engager des pour des
poursuites on peut pas se contenter de
space de laisser faire une fois plus
parce que c'est vrai quand on y détaille
non létal est à paris ne répond pas et
qu'est ce qui va se passer l'an prochain
les français vont voter comme comme il
le mérite c'est à dire extrêmement
violent de mots sur les images pour deux
pour parler vrai puisque l'expulsion des
imams radicaux ça fait des années qu'on
en parle et plusieurs gouvernements s'y
sont cassé le nez sur cette question
juridiquement juridiquement mais aussi
diplomatiquement bourg est très clair
pour expulser un animal il faut bien
tout lui trouvé que le pays vers lequel
voulait expulser soit d'accord pour
l'accueillir
or on va dire les choses très clairement
il ya des pays du maghreb notamment
l'algérie qui refuse de récupérer les
imams radicaux qui préfère les voir en
france juste du chant français ils
peuvent pas être pire il ya la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qui une
fois qu'on a réussi à les condamner et à
les expulser en algérie dit à demain
nous regarder ils vont avoir des
traitements inhumains et des tortures en
algérie donc c est donc nous on est
obligé de conserver au frais du
contribuable a réhabilité et on les loge
à l'hôtel l argument c'est dire aussi on
préfère qu'ils soient là et qu'on
surveille un petit peu ce qui se passe
autour d'eux ça n'arrive pas ici les
services qu effectivement préfère les
avoir les mêmes à disposition et qui m'a
organise une sorte de rotation des imams
ce qui on en a pas parlé mais il ya une
très très forte violence et concurrence
entre les différents courants de pensée
au sein de l'islam de france et vous
avez notamment à marseille
un cas très intéressant pas toulouse
mais marseille où un imam salafiste
vient d'être remplacée avec la
bénédiction des autorités françaises par
un animal issu des frères musulmans je
ne sais pas ce qu'on a gagné je ne sais
pas trop ce qu'on a perdu mais on voit
bien qu'il ya un jeu parfois un peu
trouble y compris des autorités
françaises sur la gestion ce qu'une
vraie gestion politique et publique de
l'islam en france
quelques réactions toujours sur ce sujet
pascal parce qu'elle est une femme
l'état de droit doit faire respecter la
loi tout simplement claude on a besoin
d'un peu d'autorité face au laxisme des
trente dernières années
léonard da l'état se cache derrière la
justice mais c'est notre justice qui
n'est pas adapté je vous livre une
histoire personnelle vous parler
d'éducation et de civisme et de ça il se
trouve que j'ai eue lors du
l'histoire dans une école du 15e
arrondissement à paris les parents
d'élèves des autres élèves voyez arriver
deux jeunes garçons accompagnés de leurs
soeurs voilée lesquels soeur accompagner
leurs enfants
enfin leurs frères jusqu'aux portes de
l'école et ensuite on rentre et on a
demandé quelques parents demander
qu'est-ce que pourquoi vous n'allez pas
l'école et les petites filles ont
répondu ah ben non moi c'est l'école à
la maison et les les autorités de
l'école enfin la direction de l'école de
laverty adia où on sait mais on peut
rien faire nathalie médias c'est faux
parce qu'ils ont non seulement ils
doivent faire enfin ils peuvent faire
ils doivent faire c'est une obligation
légale de contrôler la manière dont sont
éduqués des enfants qui sont
déscolarisés et comme on est dans un
état de droit la scolarité la
scolarisation à la maison s'il est
autorisé à partir du moment où elle est
fait dans les règles il faut il faut
contrôler et vous le verrez il est à
l'obligation contrôler que ces règles
sont appliquées ça veut dire que dans le
cas que vous citiez il ya peut-être une
école coranique dans le passé mais j'ai
beau mais c'est pas impossible on
découvre quelques fois qu'il ya un petit
une petite salle qui sert d'école et
encore une fois le chacun il ya une un
principe de liberté d'enseignement mais
à condition de le faire dans les règles
il n'empêche qu'une partie de la droite
a critiqué les conditions qui ont été
mises pour mieux contrôler les écoles
hors contrat en disant c'est une
atteinte à bien sûr bien sûr mais parce
que là on parle de choses différentes il
faut savoir que dans les écoles hors
contrat vous avez à peu près 2% d'écoles
musulmanes tout le reste soit il ya
beaucoup d'écoles montessori des écoles
non confessionnelle de il doit avoir 15%
de mémoire ou peut-être un peu plus
d'écoles catholiques des écoles juives
mais les les les musulmans n'utilise pas
forcément ce levier c'est beaucoup le
levier périscolaire les associations ou
à soi des calibrages soit des salles de
sport des associations culturelles dont
on ne sait pas trop ce qu'elles font
voilà c'est plutôt là dessus qu'il
faudra une bonne nouvelle à retenir
quand même parce que les gens qui nous
reliaient peuvent s'inquiéter
légitimement et malgré tout il ya une
vraie prise de conscience à la fois
parce qu'on dit l'état l'état l'état
c'est vrai que l'état a pris du retard
l'état s'est laissé déborder mais
aujourd'hui on n'est plus dans la même
situation saine quand on a conscience
qu'il ya une vraie menace qui est un
vrai péril on sait pas trop comment je
l'attrapé quand on est aussi en fonction
politique parce que c'est très explosive
comme sujet mais il ya une action de
fond qui est menée alors ce sera
malheureusement ce sera long parce qu'on
a on a pris trop de retard
votre troisième sujet c'est celui des
finances publiques c'est le gros